everyone involved has pursued one goal
justice we pursued justice wherever it
led
when i became the lead prosecutor for
the case i
asked for time and patience to review
the facts
gather evidence and prosecute for the
murder of george floyd to the fullest
extent
the law allowed i want to thank the
community
for giving us that time and allowing us
to do
our work that long hard painstaking
work has culminated today i would not
call today's verdict
justice however because justice implies
true restoration but it
is accountability which is the first
step towards justice
and now the cause of justice is in your
hands
and when i say your hands i mean the
hands of the people of the united states
george floyd mattered he was loved by
his family and his friends
his death shocked the conscience of our
community our
country the whole world he was loved by
his family and friends
but that isn't why he mattered he
mattered because
he was a human being and there is no way
we can turn away from that reality
the people who stopped and raised their
voices on may 25th
2020 were a bouquet of humanity
a phrase i stole from my friend jerry
blackwell
a bouquet of humanity old young
men and women black and white
a man from the neighborhood just walking
to get a drink
a child going to buy a snack with her
cousin
an off-duty firefighter on her way to a
community garden
brave young women teenagers who press
record on their cell phones
why did they stop they didn't know
george floyd
they didn't know he had a beautiful
family they didn't know
he had been a great athlete and they
didn't know he was a proud father
or that he had people in his life who
loved him
they stopped and raised their voices and
they even challenged
authority because they saw his humanity
they stopped and they raised their
voices because they knew
that what they were seeing was wrong
they didn't need to be medical
professionals or
experts in the use of force they knew it
was wrong
and they were right these community
members this bouquet of humanity
did it again in this trial
they performed simple yet profound
acts of courage they told the truth
and they told the whole world the truth
about what they saw
they were vindicated by the chief of
police
by minneapolis longest serving police
officer
and by many other police officers who
stepped up and testified
as to what they saw into what they knew
what happened on that street was wrong
we owe it and we owe our gratitude to
fulfilling their we owe them our
gratitude for fulfilling their civic
duty
and for their courage and telling the
truth to countless people in minnesota
and across the united states who join
them in peacefully demanding justice for
george floyd
we say all of us thank you
in the coming days more may seek to
express themselves again
through petition and demonstration i
urge everyone to honor the legacy of
george floyd
by doing so calmly legally
and peacefully